morning it remains a troubling trend
among teenagers
vaping is on the rise along with the
health risks for those younger users
well today in light of that is vaping
prevention and awareness day
biakoholma joining us live this morning
with more on the efforts to try and keep
teenagers from picking up the bad habit
bianca hey good morning john so these
vape pens that you can get from
convenience stores or smoke shops
they may be a better alternative for
adults trying to quit smoking but for
teens
this can really impact their health and
lead to nicotine addiction
and some of those health issues can be
impacting your immune system
in your lungs and of course even
impacting the
developing brain that teens have now
today the nevada tobacco coalition will
share new strategies and statistics
around teens and vape pins
and e-cigarettes the coalition tells us
about one in five teens admit to vaping
in the past 30 days
and that's where the teams that were
surveyed by the coalition they also say
that they get the products from
adults buying them for them there are
some changes at the federal level to
make vape pins more difficult to obtain
in nevada this upcoming legislative
session
there is a bill that would likewise
raise that age to sell products to 21.
um so there's a little
um discord right now um a lot of
retailers
are going with the federal legislation
because that
because that's that's the federal law
but nevada definitely wants to update
our law
so there are warning signs adults should
look out for if they suspect their team
could be
vaping experts say a change in mood
problems at school
or a fruity scent when you enter a room
or you can smell it on their breath
many vape pens have a fruity taste and a
sweet taste that appeals
to teens now also the american lung
association they'll be releasing a new
report
on wednesday so they'll be releasing
that tomorrow around some more
information to help
prevent teens from picking up this bad
habit reporting live from near rainbow
in sahara bianca holman 8 news now